저는 요즘에 다이소도 도파민 사업인 것 같아요.
다이소가요?
쇼치를 10분 보려고 했는데 2시간 만에
이게 다 도파민 때문이에요?
오해받는 느낌이에요.
그래요?
제가 알고 있는 개별 차이가 굉장히 큰데
도파민이라고 하면 자극이나 쾌락, 만족 이런 걸 주는 물질이라고 생각을 했거든요.
근데 실제 도파민은 그런 거 하려고 있는 애도 아니에요.
최초로 신병기가 생겨나는 애.
소비 문화의 문화 경제 이야기 비주얼 경제와 포스트를 맡은 저는 토스 김창선이고요.
저는 재문옥구 이재용입니다.
이번 주 비주얼 경제학 주제는 도파민인데요.
게스트로 뇌과학자 송민영 박사님 모셨습니다.
어서 오세요.
반갑습니다.
도파민이라는 말은 이제는 일상 단어가 저는 된 것 같아요.
자극받을 때 도파민 터진다 이런 말을 이제는 모두가 아무렇지 않게 쓰잖아요.
도파민이 정확히 어떤 물질인지 설명을 해주실 수 있을까요?
우리 중학교 때, 고등학교 때 수업 시간에, 생물 시간에 아마도 배웠을
배웠던 건가요 저희가?
네, 아마도 배웠을 겁니다.
신경세포가 세포 아래에서는 전기적 전달을 하지만 세포 사이에서는
무슨 화학적 전달한다 이런 비스무리한 거 들으신 것 같잖아요.
있었던 것 같기도 해요.
네.
그래서 그 화학적 전달, 신경세포 들 사이에 전달을 하는 애들은 신경
전달 물질이라고 우리가 배웠어요 .
근데 우리 뇌는 항상 똑같이 활동 하지 않잖아요.
내가 화날 때는 다른 자아가 나오 기도 하고 만사 귀찮을 때 되게
즐거울 때 다르단 말이에요.
네.
그래서 어떻게 하냐면 작동하는 방식을 이렇게 살짝씩 조절해 주는
물질이 필요한 거예요.
그렇죠.
개들을 신경 조절 물질이라고 하고 스위치네요 스위치.
스위치라고 하면은 조금 달라요?
좀 레버라고 할게요.
왜냐하면 양에 따라서 조절할 수 있으니까 근데 그게 하나만 있는
게 아니라 우리가 레버가 여러 개 있는 거예요.
예를 들면 아드레날린이라고 알려진 노르에피네프린 그다음 도파민
도 중요한 것 중에 하나고요.
세로토닌.
네.
그렇죠.
세로토닌 그다음 에피네프린 계열 도 이 안에 들어가게 됩니다.
저희가 일상에서 도파민이라는 단어를 그 수많은 신경 물질 중에서 쓰
잖아요.
네.
학계에서는 도파민의 위상이 어느 정도 돼요 중요성.
그 레버 중에 도파민 몇 위 정도 되냐.
네.
급이 어느 정도냐.
그런 거 중요하거든요.
네.
그렇죠.
우리가 일상에서는 뭔가 우리 수여 서열 매기고 싸움 붙이면 누가
되느냐 이런 거 좋아해요.
그렇죠.
네.
도파민 돋네요.
지금 약간.
그렇죠.
물어보고 그런데 여러분이 하필 물어본 사람이 도파민 연구하는
사람이에요.
네.
탑.
무조건 1순위죠.
최애.
나한테는 최애인데.
네.
가정연구소한테 물어보면 다른 게 말할 수도 있다.
다를 수 있다.
네.
그런데 도파민이 지난 20여 년간 내과학계 혹은 정신의학계에서
굉장히 핫한 토픽이었던 건 맞아요.
아 업계에서도 이미.
네.
좀 핫한 토픽이었던 건 맞아요.
핫한 토픽이라는 건 대중이 원하기 때문에 약간 그런 핫한.
아니요.
또 재미있는 결과들이 되게 많이 나와요.
아.
네.
어떤 거냐면 그냥 구체적인 실험을 하지 않았어요.
쥐를 그냥 이렇게 넓은 운동장 같은 데 둥그런 데 아무것도 없이
네.
넣어놓고 너 마음대로 놀아라 하고 봤어요.
음.
하면서 이제 도파민 신경세포가 가끔 이렇게 도파민을 분비할 거
아니에요.
네.
그 활동이 많아지는 시기랑 많아진 다음에 그 많아지기 직전의 행동
이랑.
네.
그 다음의 행동을 봤어요.
음.
비교를 해봤더니 예를 들어 몸을 트고 나서 도파민이 분비가 샥
요 타이밍에 분비가 됐다.
음.
그러고 나서 그 한 몇 분 정도의 활동을 봤더니 몸을 트는 행동을
예전보다 좀 더 많이 하는 거 같아요.
아.
그 행동을 하면 도파민이 나오니까.
그러니까 그쵸.
도파민 나오는 행동을 계속 하는 거네요.
그쵸.
어.
요게 딱 되게 정확한 부분인데 요게 앞으로 오늘 얘기할 중재랑도
되게 많이 관련이 돼요.
어.
이거는 뭐냐면 도파민이 학습하고 관련된다는 걸 보여주는 증거
잖아요.
아.
어.
일상에서 내가 그냥 마음대로 하고 있는데 도파민이 나왔어 그럼
그 도파민이 나오는 시점하고 관련된 행동을 나는 그 다음에 좀 더 많이
하게 되는 거예요.
아.
어.
학습이잖아요.
행동의 변화가 일어난 거니까.
네.
그래서 꼭 학습에서 핵심적인 역할을 한다.
아.
오.
오늘 얘기 엄청 기대되는.
그러니까 오늘 얘기를 관통하는 어떤 주제.
네.
그런 연구였던 것 같아요.
얘기하시네요.
어.
어쨌든 학교에서도 최근에 도파민 에 대한 재밌는 연구들이 많고
근데 무엇보다도 요즘은 진짜 도파민 이란 단어를 대중용어로
쓸 만큼 대중들의 이 도파민에 대한 관심이 많은데 박사님이 보시기
에는 요즘 대중들이 도파민에 관심이 많아진 이유 뭐라고 생각하세요
어.
학계에서 왜 관심이 많아지냐고 물으신다면 제가 답할 수 있겠지만
.
사람들이 왜 관심이 많아질까.
네.
그거를.
대중들이.
네.
그거를 물으시면 저는 사실은 대중문화 전문가가 아니어가지고 잘 모르
겠어요.
아.
네.
과학자 같아.
과학자는 모르는 건 모른다고 하거든.
딱 이렇게.
제 영역이 아닙니다.
네.
과학자는 정말 정확합니다.
내가 모르는 건 모릅니다.
네.
그럼 박사님한테 답 못 들은 부분을 제형님한테 여쭤보고 싶은데
도파민이란 단어가 대중적으로 굉장히 요즘 많이 얘기가 되고 있는
이유를 뭐라고 생각하세요.
그냥 말 그대로 절여져 있기 때문에.
그러니까 절여질 수 있는 아이템들이 너무 많아졌다.
아.
현실 세계에는.
그래서 뭐 유튜브 쇼츠 넷플릭스 기타 뭐 온라인상에서 주어질 수
있는 특히 휴대폰으로 얻을 수 있는 소스가 너무 많다 보니까.
음.
그거를 후회하게 만드는 아이템들이 많은 거죠.
왜냐하면 내가 쇼츠를 10분 보려고 그랬는데 2시간 봤어.
아.
그러면 이제 즐거운데 뒤돌아보면 공허함이 느껴지잖아요.
음.
왜 그랬을까.
아 이게 다 도파민 때문이야.
음.
그러면 도파민은 무엇이지.
그래서 이제 뇌과학직을 보게 되는 약간 그런 상황이지 않을까라
싶긴 해요.
어떤.
어떠세요.
오해받는 느낌이에요.
그래요.
아 그래요.
아 이게 도파민에 대한 오해다.
이게 다 도파민 때문이야.
오해받는 느낌이에요.
약간.
지금 다 도파민 탓이야 이러고 있는데 그게 아니다.
그래요.
오해받고 착하고 좋은 애인데 너무 오해받는 느낌이에요.
아 약간 불량식품같이 취급되는 게.
네.
아.
얘는 비타민 같은 애에요.
아니 근데 특히나 이 도파민의 부정적인 좀 의미가 씌워지게 된 게 도파민
중독.
맞아요.
이라고 많이 쓰잖아요.
이렇게 묶어서.
맞아요.
네.
실제 도파민에 중독이 된다는 말이 좀 사실인가요.
아닙니다.
제가 되게 여러 매체에서 말을 했는데.
어.
도파민에 중독이 될 수는 없습니다.
없어요.
네.
중독이라는 표현은 주로 어떤 데 쓰냐면.
저기 저희 자체를 얘기할게요.
우리가 어떤 행동을 하는데 방금 말씀하셨잖아요.
보고 나는데 막 허무해.
어.
후회돼.
나한테 인생이 별로 안 좋아.
응.
그래서 그걸 아는데도 불구하고.
그렇죠.
통제가 안 되는 거예요.
네.
막 만찬 솟혀놓고 막 하게 돼.
그런 상태를 중독이라고 불러요.
맞아요.
그게 약물일 수도 있고.
응.
숏츠나 게임이나 쇼핑 같은 행동일 수도 있어요.
도박 같은.
응.
그거 행동과 물질에 대해 중독된다고 하지 도파민에 중독된다라고
할 수는 없어요.
아.
그렇죠.
그러니까 도박을 해서 도파민이 터졌다.
그래서 내가 도박을 많이 하게 됐다.
그러면 도파민 중독이냐 도박 중독 이냐 물어보면 도박 중독이다.
그렇죠.
아.
시원합니다.
네.
아.
도파민이 억울하겠다.
도파민 중독 물질이 아니다라는 거죠.
그렇죠.
정확합니다.
아니.
잠깐 이야기 나눠봤는데 확실히 대중들이 생각하는 도파민과 박사
님이 연구하시는 진짜 도파민의 차이 오해가 확실히 있는 것 같아요.
네.
지금 떨어지고 있는 건 사실인 것 같아요.
박사님도 좀 체감을 하시나요 일단 adhd라고 하는 단어 자체가 원래는
알려져 있기를 성인 adhd는 적다 그렇게 적다 성인이 되면서 이거는 도파민
신경세포가 전전두엽으로 이렇게 가거든요.
이 거리가 되게 길어요.
네.
여기까지 가는 게 만 20세 정도 초반 정도까지 가야 이 발달이 충분히
이루어지게 되거든요.
네.
그러면 이제 발달이 되니까 없어지는 경향이 대부분이다.
해소가 됩니다.
네.
그런데 최근에는 성인 adhd다 성인 인데 adhd 이런 사람들 되게 많잖아요
.
네.
많아졌어요.
많았잖아요.
제가 방금 말씀드린 일상적인 집중이고 내과학에서 말하는 attention
한 가지가 더 있어요.
그래요.
top down과 bottom up이라고도 얘기를 하는데 우리가 방금 얘기한 건 이제
top down에 해당이 되고 bottom up은 뭐냐면 여기서 뭔가 소리가 쾅 하고 들렸어요
.
네.
봐야 되잖아요.
그래야 나의 안전을 위해서.
그런데 뭔가 이렇게 쾅쾅 터지는 자극들이 좀 많아지는 시대에 살고
있는 것 같아요.
네.
그래서 오프라인에서 살 때는 물론 좀 덜하지만 우리는 온라인에서
많은 시간을 보내고 그런데 온라인 은 여기저기에서 나를 클릭해 줘
하는 팡팡 터지는 게 많은 세상이 잖아요.
네.
그러니까 그런 문제가 하나 있다 보니까 일단 디스트릭트라고 하죠
.
집중하던 대상에서 이렇게 외국 스위치하는 거.
이렇게 외국 다른 쪽으로 이렇게 다른 쪽을 보게 되는.
네.
그러니까 그런 것들이 좀 많아지는 일단 시대가 된 것 같고 또 하나는
우리는 마음이 편안해야 집중할 수 있어요.
그렇죠.
막 불안하고 초조한데 집중하기는 힘들어요.
네.
그런데 기본적으로 경쟁이라든가 그다음 마음은 몸에 따라 갈 수밖에
없는데 먹는 거 이상하지 생체리즘 요즘 다 깨져 있을 때 많지 그러다
보니까 뇌가 하여튼 생물학적으로 도 호모사피엔스의 생태라는 측면
에서 봐서도 집중하기 힘든 상황이 된 게 아닌가 이 두 가지 정도를
저는 생각하고 있습니다.
어쨌든 지금 사람들이 가장 원하는 건 어쨌든 이 쇼츠나 쇼폰 플랫폼
이 제공하는 도파민을 계속 자극 시키는 이 함정에서 벗어나고 싶은
거잖아요.
네.
박사님이 혹은 이게 함정에서 벗어나는 방법을 혹시 추천해 주신다면 어떤
게 있을까요
도파민이 중독에 일으킨다고 오해 되는 이유는 중독성 물질 중독성
쾌락에만 분비된다고 사람들이 믿기 때문이거든요.
그런데 실제 도파민은 그런 거 하려고 있는 애가 아니에요.
최초로 신경기가 생겨나던 무렵 부터 도파민이라는 애는 있었고
얘는 뭘 하기 위해서냐면 우리의 생존에 필요한 움직임을 좀 더 잘
만들어내기 위해서 그 움직임을 더 잘하고 더 자주 하기 위해서
있었던 애란 말이에요.
그래서 얘는 그런 나쁜 데만 있는 게 아니라 우리 삶의 소소한 즐거움
등 사람들하고 즐거운 교류를 했을 때 아니면 운동을 했을 때 항상
나온단 말이에요.
그래서 그런 다른 즐거움들이 더 많아질 수 있으면 굳이 여기에 얘
가 주는 도파민에 우리가 몰입할 필요가 없잖아요.
그런데 우리가 쇼츠를 본다는 건 어떻게 생각하면 슬픈 거예요.
우리는 사람들하고 만날 정신적인 여유나 아니면 밖에 놀러 나갈 시간적이거나
감정적인 여유가 부족하니까 제일 싼 도파민 공급처가 뭐예요
.
쇼츠잖아요.
그렇죠.
어떻게 생각하면 슬픈 거예요.
그래서 도파민을 만드는 애들 좀 다 변화시킬 수 있으면 좋을 것 같고
또 하나는 핸드폰 자체의 사용을 좀 낮춘다거나 하는 것도 저는 도움이
될 것 같아요.
그러니까 보통 사람들은 이제 도파민 자체가 나쁘다는 오해가 있으니까
도파민을 끊어야 된다고 생각해서 그냥 어떤 자극도 받지 않으려고
꼭 참는데 박사님의 추천은 도파민 이라는 거.
그것은 좋은 거고 다른 도파민을 충족시킬 수 있는 더 즐거운 자극을 찾아라
이렇게 해석할 수 있겠네요.
그렇죠.
네.
도파민에 대한 오해를 바로 잡는 것부터가 시작이겠네요.
그렇습니다.
이쯤에서 재용 님 생각도 궁금한데 재용 님은 좀 도파민을 자주 찾으시는
편인가요
찾죠.
찾는 경우는 보통 이제 일단 의식적이지 않은 경우는 첫 번째 일할 때.
저는 일을 되게 좋아하거든요.
일이라는 게 남이 시킨 일이 아니라 내가 스스로 하는 일.
그래서 내가 이렇게 방송을 하거나 강의를 하거나.
네.
뭐 이렇게 누군가를 도와줬을 때 만약에 그 사람이 감사합니다.
너무 큰 도움이 됐습니다.
그러면은 올라오는.
너무 건전한 도파민이네요.
네.
진짜.
내 일을 하기 잘했어.
아 진짜.
핵노잼.
그러면 대중들이 어쨌든 도파민 하면 떠오르는 가장 큰 이슈.
쇼츠.
네.
그러니까 쇼츠가 잘 된다는 얘기는 5년 넘게 들었는데 체감상으로는
작년부터 확실히 좀 압도적으로 늘어나는 것 같더라고요.
숫자로도 좀 그런 트렌드가 보이나요
아주 완벽하게 최근 데이터는 찾을 수도 없긴 한데.
정부의 ceo인 닐 모안이라는 분이 계신데 그분이 이제 한 페스티벌에서
이런 얘기를 했어요.
이제 2025년에 쇼츠의 일일 조회수가 2000억 회를 넘었다.
근데 그게 또 다시 찾아보면 23년 말이나 24년 초에는 700억 회였
거든요.
불과 1년이나 1년 반 사이에 700억 회가 2000억 회가 된 거예요.
그렇게 우리는 알고리즘의 노예가 되고 있다.
그러면 이런 쇼츠 플랫폼 외에 도파민 자극이라는 요소를 가지고 비즈니스
를 굴리는.
응.
뭐 다 있죠 어떻게 보면은 이제 흔히 아는 메타 구글 틱톡 얘가 3대
장이고.
3대장이고.
네.
주가 올라가는 3대장이고.
그리고 저는 요즘에 다이소도 도파민 사업인 것 같아요.
다이소가요
1000원이잖아요.
한 20개 집어요 사람들이 거기서 괜찮은 아이템이 생기면 이제 기분이
좋거든요.
그러면 이제 그 기억을 가지고 또 찾게 돼요.
적은 돈으로 계속해서 이제 까보면서 뭔가 이렇게 좀 좋은 건지 안 좋은
건지.
그렇죠.
그리고 시장도 도파민 터지는 장점이에요.
요즘 만큼 예 도파민이 터지는.
예측이 안 됩니다.
요즘 만큼 토스에서 알림이 많이 온 적이 없어요.
최고가입니다.
최고가를 찍었어요.
최고가 찍었어요.
역대 최고가입니다.
전 국민이 약간 도파민 파티하고 있는 것 같다.
그러니까.
지금까지 현 시대에 어떤 도파민 에 대한 이야기랑 오해에 대한 얘기를
잠깐 나눠봤는데 아까 도파민은 학습이랑 연결되는 부분이 되게
많다고 이야기해 주셨잖아요.
네.
좀 더 자세히 좀 얘기를 해 주시죠.
도파민이 어떻게 학습이랑 연결이 되는지.
아까 예측이 안 돼요 하면서 도파민 얘기하셨거든요.
되게 중요한 키포인트를 말씀하실 거예요.
그렇죠.
예측.
왜냐하면 사람도 그렇고 우리가 태어났을 때는 답을 몰라요.
내가 어떤 정확하게 어떤 세상에서 살지도 모르고 답도 몰라요.
그래서 우리는 어떻게 해야 되냐면 시행착오를 겪어보면서 이거 해보니까
좋았어.
더 해야지.
이거 해보니까 안 좋았어.
덜 해야지.
하게 돼요.
이렇게 시행착오를 통해서 좋았던 거는 더 얻을 수 있는 방법을 배워
가고 안 좋았던 거는 점점 안 하는 거.
이걸 강화 학습.
강화 학습이라고 합니다.
강화 학습.
네.
이거는 사람뿐만 아니라 모든 동물 들이 다 하는 거고요.
최근에 인공지능 발달도 강화 학습.
아.
인공지능.
네.
그럼 이 강화 학습이라는 게 도파민이랑 또 어떻게 연결이 되는지.
좋은 질문이죠.
네.
그 강화 학습을 할 때 사람들한테 는 생명체한테는 보상이라고 하는
안전이 됐든 음식이 됐든 친구가 됐든 그런 것들의 보상에 대한 예측
을 내가 정확히 할 수 있어요.
네.
예측이 크면 행동을 많이 바꿀 거고 예측이 작으면 행동을 조금
바꿀 거고.
네.
이렇게 하면서 배워갈 수 있잖아요 .
그래서 최종적으로 예측이 없는 순간 예측과 현실과의 차이 이걸
예측 오류라고 하는데 예측 오류 가 없는 순간이 내가 이거 마스터
한 순간이잖아요.
아.
그렇죠.
내가 정확하게 아는 거잖아요.
예측이.
그렇죠.
그런데 뚜둔.
90년대가 되고 보니까.
네.
이 예측 오류랑 도파민 신호랑 패턴 이 너무 비슷한 거예요.
대박.
네.
아니 어떻게 이거는 인공지능 쪽에서 나오는 건데 신경과학에서
하니까 맞았어.
아 맞을까 진짜 맞아 하는 거를 이제 2000년대 2010년대 계속 본
거예요.
네.
계속 본대 맞네 맞네 진짜 맞아.
어.
인 거였던 거예요.
아.
네.
그래서 도파민은 예측 오류를 신호 함으로써 강학습에서 굉장히 중요한
역할을 한다.
음.
는 게 학계에서 말하고 있는 대표적인 정설 중에 하나예요.
지금 약간 새로운 단어들이 많아 가지고 예를 한번 들어보면 생각해
보면 좋을 것 같은데.
저희가 여행 갈 때 막 이렇게 돈을 썼어요.
음.
즐겁게 하고 돈을 썼는데.
네.
10만 원 사이즈라고 예상을 하고 하루 시작을 했어요.
하루 잘 놀았어요.
음.
놀았는데 보니까 15만 원을 썼네.
네.
그러니까 5만 원만큼 더 쓴 거잖아요.
5만 야 나 5만 원 더 썼어.
음.
알려주는 게 도파민.
아.
그 차이를 알려주는.
예.
줄여.
예산 줄여.
내일은 돈 좀 아꼈어.
어떤 어떤 부분을 많이 썼으니까 이거는 좀 줄여.
그렇죠.
그걸 알려주는 게 도파민의 역할이다.
요 크기를 알려줬으니까.
음.
내가 긍정적인 활동을 더하게 에너지를 만들어주고.
그렇죠.
부정적이면 그걸 수정할 수 있는 에너지를 만들어주고.
아 정리 정말 잘하시네.
네.
그게 도파민이다.
그러므로서 우리는 예측 오류를 점점 줄여나가도록 행동을 하게
된다.
그렇죠.
그러므로서 우리는 나은 사람이 된다.
네.
아니 지금 제가 알고 있는 갭의 차이가 굉장히 큰데.
그러니까 도파민이라고 함은 소위 이제 생각이나 정신 속에서 어떤
자극이나 쾌락 약간 만족 이런 걸 주는 물질이라고 생각을 했거든요
.
그런데 그게 아니라 그걸 알려주는 어떤 시그널 신호.
우리는 도파민을 즐거움이라고 약간 생각했는데.
약간 콜라 같은 거라고 생각했는데 맛있는 거라고.
그런데 지금 듣다 보니까 도파민 그냥 선생님인 거야.
네.
맞아요.
정확한 이유입니다.
네.
사실 쾌락이라는 느낌은 도파민이 equal 쾌락 호르몬으로 잘못 알려져
있는데 쾌락이라는 느낌은 오피오이드 계열이 훨씬 더 많이 하고 있고요.
도파민이랑 다른 애예요.
네.
도파민은 쾌락보다는 학습 혹은 살짝 뭔가 배워야 되니까 내가
도파민의 효과 중에 살짝 조금 더 긴장시키는 조금 더 각성되게 만드는
그런 효과에 조금 더 가깝지 쾌락 은 도파민이 아니라 오피오이드 계열
이에요.
그러면 좀 이제 너무 저희 입장에서 문과 입장에서 너무 깊게 들어간
것 같아요.
약간 현실 레벨로 좀 돌아오고 그러니까 도파민은 나에게 이롭게 활용할
수 있는 그런 학습이나 이런 쪽으로 활용할 수 있는 그런 방식이랑 중독
의 영역으로 들어가는 그런 좀 좋지 않은 형태의 그런 행동 이거 두 개
차이는 좀 어떤 게 있는 거예요 .
자 이렇게 볼게요.
내가 음식을 먹었어요.
내가 위산을 분비하려고 의지를 발휘를 해야 위산이 나오나요 그냥
나오나요.
그냥 나오죠.
그렇죠.
내가 도파민을 좋게 활용을 하려고 해서 의지를 해서 나오는 게 아니라
도파민은 내가 머릿속에 가지고 있는 세상은 이런 곳이야 라고 하는
그 모델과 실제 경험과의 차이만큼 그냥 도파민을 그냥 분비를 시키는
거예요.
그래서 내가 만일에 도파민의 분비를 조절을 하고 싶다면 나의 세계관이나
그것도 조금 바꿔줘야 같이 바꿔 줘야 조절이 됩니다.
그래서 예를 들어서 내가 인서울 에 대학에 취직을 해서 졸업하고
나면 바로 이제 대기업 취직을 해서 적어도 서른 전에는 집을 사서 결혼
해서 이렇게 쫙쫙 라인들을 딱 가지고 있어.
그러면 이제 대한민국이 현실적인 통계적인 삶을 산다고 생각을 해
봤을 때 이 사람은 계속 그 예측 오류가 계속 마이너스인 거예요
.
그렇죠.
그럼 이 사람은 내가 아무리 노력 을 해도 예측 오류가 계속 마이너스
니까 예측 오류가 마이너스면 행동 을 안 하게 되잖아요.
그러다 보면 결국 어떤 정도로까지 갈 수 있게 되냐면 저는 이게 요즘
우리나라의 은둔현 청년들 이런 거랑 또 관련이 있다고 생각을 해요
.
그런데 아까 말씀하신 나는 서울 자가의 대기업 단위는 뭐가 될 거야
같은 아주 높은 기준이라는 건 내 마음이 그냥 그렇게 정하면 그 기준
에 맞게 나의 예측 오류랑 이런 것들이 다 조정이 가능한 거예요
.
그 사람이 어느 순간 서울 자가를 포기하면 그때부터는 예측 오류가
졸여들면서 그 전보다 행복한 상태가 될 수 있는 거예요
.
그 포기라고 하는 게 의식적으로 포기하는 거랑 진심으로 포기하는
거랑 이런 것들이 좀 조절이 돼야 될 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 이 세계관에 맞춰서 우리 도파민이 분비량이 조절이 되고
우리 행동이 바뀌잖아요.
그래서 이 세계관이라는 거는 자 오늘부터 이렇게 하기로 결심하겠어
한다고 딱 바뀌는 게 아니라 나의 삶을 거쳐서 어떤 사회적인 컨텍스트
에서 살아가면서 만들어진 빚어진 거란 말이에요.
네.
그래서 그게 빚어진 것이기 때문에 .
개인으로서 혼자 하기 힘든 부분도 있을 거예요.
네.
사회가 좀 프레임도 있으니까.
그렇죠.
무슨 영화에서처럼 대단한 경험을 겪고 바뀌는 경우도 물론 있어요
.
그러나 그게 그렇게 쉽게 바뀌지 않을 것 같아요.
마음처럼 그렇죠.
우리 세계관을 바꾸는 건 쉽지는 않은데 결론적으로는 예측 오류가
생기면 플러스 예측 오류면 그것을 더 많이 하도록 이제 도파민이 우리
한테 지시를 내릴 것이 도파민이 실제로 내리는 건 아니겠지만 더
행동을 하게 만들고 마이너스 예를 들어서 수익 측면에서 마이너스
예측 오류면 그걸 좀 덜 하도록 우리 한테 지시를 내리는 게 도파민
이다.
도파민이라는 게 즐거울 때만 나오는 것도 아니고 슬플 때만 나오는 것도
아니고 어쨌든 기대와 크게 차이가 났을 때 생기는 거니까.
그렇죠.
네.
그것도 맞고 그다음에 크기랑 빈도를 조절하는 것 상의 타협도 필요해요
.
그러니까 저는 특히 좀 금방금방 지루해지는 타입이라서 그렇기도
한데 우리는 왜 뭔가 큰 목표를 설정해 놓고 이게 되고 나면 행복할 거예요
라고 생각한단 말이에요.
네.
도파민은 학습하는 애잖아요.
예측 오류를 줄이는 게 목적이에요 .
그렇기 때문에 크고 좋은 걸 보고 나서도 계속 같은 크기의 예측 오류
가 나올 수가 없어요.
얘는 줄어들 거고 얘에 대한 만족 은 금방 떨어질 거예요.
그래서 나한테 작은 예측 오류를 주는 사건들이 자주 있는 게 좋고
저는 이제 나이가 조금 들었거든요 .
그래서 그런지는 모르겠지만 운동 을 하거나 여행을 가거나 사회생활
하거나 이런 데 돈을 좀 더 자주 하는데 돈을 더 쓰게 되긴 하더라고요
.
예측 오류랑 이제 도파민의 관계 에 대해서는 얼추 이해한 것 같아요
다음 단계로 넘어가서.
네.
이런 것도 좀 궁금해요.
그러니까 사실은 삶에서는 내가 다 계획하고 준비하고 진행했던
방식으로만 결과를 얻는 게 아니라 운이라는 요소도 좀 꽤 크게 작용
을 하잖아요.
참 중요하죠.
그런데 운이라는 개념은 과학에서 사실을 제대로 다루고 있는 개념
이긴 한지 특히나 말씀하시는 그런 강화학습이나 도파민 개념에서 운
이라는 게 어떤 역할을 하는지도 궁금하네요.
운을 실험에서 조절될 수 있는 부분 과 조절될 수 없는 요소로 보는
게 더 좋을 것 같아요.
우리가 의도적으로 조절할 수 없는 것만 발생하는 차이들이 있잖아요
.
그런데 그런 것들을 우리는 아마 운이라고 부르는 게 아닌가 싶고
과학적인 데피니션은 아니에요 .
그런데 강화학습에서는 강화학습 이 제대로 되면 이게 필요합니다.
운이요
없으면 안 돼요.
네.
일부러 집어넣어요.
그래요 네.
그럼 통제하고 예측할 수 있는 범위 안에서만 하는 게 그런 강화학습
에 핵심적이라고 생각합니다.
생각을 해볼게요.
내가 예를 들어서 길을 걸어가는 연습을 해요.
길을 걸어가는 로봇을 내가 가르 치는데 로봇한테 우연적인 요소를
집어넣지 말고 딱 맞는 답을 찾아서 그것만 가르쳐요.
그냥 평지만 쭉 걷게 만드는 거.
그러면 얘는 평지만 걷는 것만 배웠어요.
길이 예를 들어 울퉁불퉁한데 계단 이 나와.
그럼 얘는 못하는 거예요.
그런데 일부러 처음부터 다른 여러 가지를 좀 학습시켜보고 조율을
하게 만들어주면 얘는 약간의 현실의 노이즈 나 이런 것도 극복할 수 있는
역량을 가지면서 역량의 폭을 넓 히면서 하게 되는 거예요.
혹은 그런 것도 되고 혹은 이제 세상에 보면 나는 이쪽 길만 맞다고
생각하고 가는 것보다는 가끔 이쪽 길로 가는데 지름길이야 혹은 풍경
이 더 좋아 맛있는 집 맛집이 있어 이런 게 있을 수 있단 말이에요.
그래서 내가 아는 세상에 대한 세계관이 좁기 때문에 그 세계관을
교정하기 위해서 개선하기 위해서라도 뭔가 랜덤한 우연적인 행동이 필요할
수가 있거든요.
그러네.
그러니까 약간 인공지능에서 그래서 약간 랜덤성이 되게 중요하고 그래서
요즘 자율주행에서 보면 그동안에 이제 자동차 회사들이 자율주행
을 잘하기 위해서 룰 베이스드의 ai를 많이 연구를 했어요.
그래서 내가 모든 상황을 코딩해 가지고 시속 얼마 어떤 상황에서는
멈춰라 달려라.
네.
다 실패했단 말이죠.
그렇죠.
말만 들어도 안 될 것 같아요.
그래서 이제 엔드투엔드 방식으로 하라.
엔드투엔드 방식이라고 하면 그냥 가고 그 카메라로 나오는 걸 모든
것을 모든 변칙적인 상황들을 학습 해서 너가 알아서 판단하게 하라
라고 해서 요즘은 이제 엔드투엔드 가 정답인 것처럼 많이 바뀌었거든
요.
네.
그렇죠.
그게 어떻게 보면 말씀하신 운과 강화학습의 관계인 것이다.
네.
왜냐하면 삶은 세상에는 어차피 다양한 일들이 일어나는데 그리고 얘가
충분한 경험을 할 수 있도록 운을 좀 잘 설계해야 되는 거죠.
운을 좀 잘 설계해서 죽지는 않을 만큼 그러나 배울 수 있을 만큼 그걸
적절한 타이밍에 잘 넣어줘야지만 에이전트가 잘 배우더라 이게 있는
거죠.
네.
그래서 그걸 사람으로 생각을 하더라도 처음부터 어떤 사람한테 너무 과
하게 가면 발달이 제대로 안 돼요 .
그 사람의 그 시기에 맞는 정도의 운과 변이가 있어야 되는데 안 되면
발달이 안 되거나 뭐 불행하게도 죽게 되거나 뭐 이런 게 있는 거죠
.
그렇죠.
가슴을 부여잡는 이유가 부모라서 그래요.
요즘 아이들이 이제 보면 내 동라이 때에 비해 너무 어리다라는 생각을
많이 하거든요.
왜 그럴까 왜 이게 정서적으로도 이게 왜 이렇게 어릴까라고 생각해
보면 부모가 계속 모든 상황을 통제 하려고 해요.
아이가 너무 많은 스트레스를 받지 않고 너무 많은 예측하지 못한 상황을
어떻게 보면 부모가 해주고 딱 약간 실험실 같은 형태의 너는 정말 이렇게
완벽하게 커야 돼 라는 형태로 아이들을 키우는데 그러다 보니까 아이가 강화학습을 할 기회를 많이 갖죠.
네.
그렇죠.
그리고 전부 다 통제된 환경에서만 학습하기도 하고.
그러니까 성장이 더딘 거지.
이거 맞나요.
맞아요.
이렇게 쉽게 이해할 수 있네.
네.
그러니까 아이는 일단 흙도 파먹고 혼자서 알아서 길도 가보고 해야
되는데.
손을 대보고.
흙먹지 마라 길 정해진 길만 가라 자꾸 이런 친구만 만나라 이렇게
하니까 아이가 성장을 못하는 거죠 .
저는 그 운을 예전에는 나한테 주어지는 어떤 선물 보따리 같은 거라고 생각
했거든요.
당연히 주어지는 선물 보따리.
그런데 요즘 드는 생각은 나한테 주어진 것을 내가 어떻게 해석하느냐
의 차이라고 생각을 하는 것 같아요 .
가령 길 가다가 자동차 사고가 났 는데 내가 다친 곳이 없어.
그러면 운이 좋다고 느끼는 사람은 내가 다친 곳이 하나도 없네 라고
해석을 해서 운이 좋다고 해석을 하고 운이 안 좋다고 생각하는 사람은
길 가는데 내가 왜 사고가 났지 하면서 운이 안 좋다고 생각을 할
것 같거든요.
그래서 운은 약간 이거 운입니다 이러면서 주는 무언가가 아니라
나한테 닥치는 여러.
어떤 시나리오나 에피소드에 대한 해석 같은 느낌이 좀 들더라고요
.
그러니까 어떻게 받아들이냐에 따라 다르다.
이게 운이라는 게 위로도 차이가 날 수 있지만 아래로도 차이가 날
수 있거든요.
그렇죠.
많은 사람들은 운을 luck이라고 알고 있고 luck은 플러스라고만 생각하는
경향이 있는 것 같아서 그러니까 이 밑으로 내려가는 것도 운이고 랜덤
이다라는 거는 저는 얘기하고 싶은데
저도 완전히 동의합니다.
그렇죠.
에젠트를 학습을 시키려고.
과학 학습 에젠트를 학습시키려고.
시뮬레이션을 돌려요.
파라미터 다 똑같아요.
그런데 이제 우연적인 요소를 일부러 설계하잖아요.
배우기 하려고.
하다 보면 똑같은데 하다가 죽는 경우가 있고.
살아남는 애가 있고.
못하고 뜨는 경우가 있고.
살아남는 경우가 있어요.
그래서 운이라고 하는 거는 이제 해석을 할 수 있는 건 살아남았
기 때문인 것 같아요.
다만 어쨌거나 내가 좋은 거건 나쁜 건 살아냈잖아요.
살아내는 거를 좀 더 나한테 유용 하게 쓸 수 있는 툴들이 있으면
좋겠어요.
마치 세계관이 평가 기준점을 제공 을 해 주듯이 좋은 걸로부터는 내가
뭘 배웠고 뭘 어떻게 경험을 더 잘 쓸 수 있고 나쁜 걸로부터도 여기서
뭘 배워서 뭘 쓸 수 있는지 이런 거를 할 수 있는 전문적인 훈련
시각 이런 것들이 있다면 좀 이렇게 잘 뽑아먹을 수 있을 것 같아요.
하나의 경험으로부터 더 많은 것을 .
저도 이제 공감이 되게 많이 가는 게 제가 제일 자주 하는 말 중에
하나가 그럴 수 있었거든요.
.
그럴 수 있어.
잘 돼도 그럴 수 있고 안 돼도 그럴 수 있어.
하지만 중요한 거는 이제 피드백 이 또 중요하다고 말씀하시는 거
잖아요.
그렇죠.
아 정리 너무 잘했어요.
.
피드백이 중요하다.
그러니까 뭔가 어떤 상황이 있을 때 그것들을 기록하고 또 요즘에는
또 이제 ai가 워낙 문답을 잘해 주죠.
옛날에는 그 피드백을 나 혼자 해야 돼서 힘들었는데 ai한테 나 이런
상황이 있었는데 내가 어떻게 해야 될까 이런 상황을 어떻게 생각해
라고 물어볼 우리 친구가 생겼 잖아요.
그런 식으로 ai를 활용하면서 내 인생을 이제.
.
만들어나가는 것도 되게 의미있을 것 같다는 생각이 들어요.
끝내기 전에 이 이야기도 궁금한데 지금까지 인공지능과 인간의 뇌가
어떻게 스스로 학습하고 수정해 나가는지 비교해서 이야기를 해
봤는데 사실 사람들의 요즘 가장 큰 걱정은 과연 사람의 뇌가 인공지능
을 당해낼 수 있을 것인가인 것 같아요 .
박사님은 좀 어떻게 생각을 하세요 .
그 질문에 약간의 어폐가 있어요 .
어폐가 있어요.
보통 약간 경쟁 관계로도 되잖아요 .
네.
인간과 인공지능이.
그렇죠.
인공지능을 주체로 놓고 있는 건데 그 인공지능의 뒤에는 사람이 있어요
.
책임을 지는.
그렇죠.
그 인공지능을 설계하고 운영하는 주체 예를 들면 구글이나 이런 다국적인
거대 기업들이 되겠죠.
그다음에 그 서비스가 어떤 나라 안에서 혹은 eu 같은 체제 안에서
작동할 수 있도록 제한 제도를 만들어주는 사람이 있겠죠.
그래서 인공지능과 사람으로 놓을 게 아니라 이 인공지능의 작동양
식에 영향을 주는 사람들과 나머지 사람들 이렇게 보는 게 맞을 것
같아요.
그러니까 지금 이제 근대 현대를 거치면서 정부 대 국민 사이의 관계
에서는 어느 정도 정부를 통제할 수 있는 영향을 시민들이 많이 획득
을 했거든요.
그런데 지금과 같은 기술 대기업과 나머지 국민들 시민들 사이에 어떻게
잘 조절하면서 좋은 세상을 만들어 갈 것인가에 대한 이거는 새로운
시대적 과제예요.
그러네.
네.
그래서 우리가 이제 논의하고 이런저런 소규모로 기술 만들어서 실험해
보고 제도 만들어보고 시행착오를 겪으면서 만들어서 다음 세대에 물려
줘야 될 부분이기 때문에.
그래서 우리만이 아니라 세계 각지 에서 실험을 하고 있고요.
진짜 관심이 있다면 책을 보시고 거기서부터 쌓아가시는 걸 저는
추천드리고 싶어요.
네.
혹시 추천할 만한 책이 있을까요?
데이비드 이글만이라는 사람이 쓴 브레인.
여러분이 일반적으로 가지고 있는 질문에서 시작하잖아요.
그런데 그 질문을 질문하면서.
우리가 되게 기본적으로 가지고 있는 질문에 대한 답변을 꼬리를
물면서 가는.
질문을 답을 하는 게 아니라 그 질문을 내가 이걸 묻는 게 맞아라는
생각을 하게 되면서 내에 대한 이해를 높일 수 있도록 만들어져 있는 책
이.
소비 문화 이면에 경제 이야기 비주얼 경제와 오늘은 송민영 박사님과
함께 이야기를 나눠봤고요.
저희는 다음 시간에 다른 주제로 돌아오겠습니다.
감사합니다.